so I'm going to talk about a map of the
stack I'm going to talk about the PI
data stack now in march 2016 and how you
would solve problems using this stack so
um giovanni actually mispronounce my
name so i'm going to take this slide in
every talk i give now for now on um i'm
patrick oil and i'm known as spring coil
on at on twitter and this is my github
and there's gonna be there's no books
online of the code examples i'm going to
use I used to be involved these
companies amazon Vodafone and job today
for those who don't look a job today is
it's a job market place and I'm a
contributor to PI MC 3m and I have a
book which I want you all to buy because
I get an insult for how little sales I'm
getting which is a collection of
interviews with data scientists 24 from
around the world and clean people from
etsy Spotify Cameron Davis and pylons in
there and Hadley Wickham on various
others so my next venture and moving to
London to join the team at channel 4 and
the work of recommendation engines so
I'm really looking forward to mackeys
talk later on about recommendation
engines um and for Lucy don't know it's
a TV channel in the UK so firstly Python
3 has happened so please everybody get
on board ignore James he'll tell you
other things but you know you know most
libraries now according to a recent
analysis of pipe i have moved to python
3 so please don't like destroy your
company's intellectual property by not
moving with the future so it's march
2016 I want to do analytics and PI data
it depends on what you want to do it's
very influenced by Rob story give a
similar talk last year I'll talk a
little bit about statistics and machine
learning and it'll be no bikes involved
why would you use pison for analytics I
can ask this question about once a week
and why not use Java um so although
pricing is not very fast for web servers
you've probably something like go it's
very fast for hpc and numerics
you know because of things like see in
Fortran maybe in the future rust
although that might be controversial and
piano which is used in PI mc3 and
various deep learning frameworks so
that's kind of the strengths so but the
challenge of these strengths is that
it's an ecosystem right and the
challenge one ecosystem is it's
complicated right so I'm going to give
you a subjective term of this ecosystem
and it's thanks to these sort of people
continue my heart Cloudera inria Spotify
and many many others open source can
thrive without industrial and academic
support it does not happen just in the
weekends and these are kind of the stack
is right now right so you've got lots of
stuff you got spa see you got for
natural language processing you've got
carers for deep learning you can x array
for multi labeled data you've got
Jupiter starts models book bouquet and
various others so I'm going to talk a
little bit about these and hopefully
tell you where you would use these tools
what do you use these tools for what
these tools are not for of course the
worst part about giving this is I'll get
emails from every library author
afterwards apart like no that's not
quite true so well that's a good way to
increase the knowledge of the community
so I'm going to talk about what's new
and PI D and it quite quickly I'm going
to talk about what tools to use and I'm
going to use the distinction I think
andreas introduced yesterday as one of
his talks of in-memory art of core and
distributed I'm going to talk a little
bit like statistical tools including pi
mc3 because I'm involved in its my talk
and but you should really use it it's
really cool and I'm going to talk a
little bit about the future so what's
new and useful and PI data so it's
impossible to give a talk with like
talking about numpy and pandas and we've
improvements throughout the stack with a
better colors and laptop lid sim please
go a new release there's improvements in
Nam p there's a new ad operator which
greatly simplifies linear algebra code
you've got a sign and pipe and pandas
and various new things coming through
with the new release which will be a lot
more stable API and here's an example of
why we use a sign
and if you wanted to create like a
logarithmic column you know based on the
other data it's quicker and it's easy to
pipe together with the other operators
so so so far it's kind of like this is
what we feel right we've done things
quite well you know but there's more to
PI data than just numpy and pandas so I
have a data problem it's 2016 I want to
solve this and practice I want to
groupon kind things all we do all day is
accountancy right so I'm going to use
the adult data set and this is from the
UCI data set it's got categoricals
various variables standard data set you
can easily download and I have a CSV
version attached to this this code so i
can only use the standard library i'm
stuck on a restricted machine and i only
have python 2.6 this has actually
happened unfortunately um like and this
example is influenced by Rob stories
example but I wrote something pretty
similar myself so you have to write your
own conversion map right you can use CSV
file you can come up with your own like
data structures you know comparisons
it's not too difficult and you can do a
converter and you can load to csv source
and it looks relatively good as a decent
data structure so let's kind in group
you can get your max age or if you want
to be even better you can use something
like a generator expression which is
even faster and more pythonic and you
can do something like default date right
you can copy your own like you know
group or structure this is not fast but
if you had to use python 2.6 you were
stuck on another computer and you had no
ability to install anything year you
could do this and then you can get
things like the mean number of hours by
occupation so this is a standard thing
that I'm going to compare via different
methods by a different technique by a
different libraries your throughout you
know the standard kind of benchmark now
if you don't know about a turtle's you
know it's it's worth reminding you you
know so it's very difficult to build a
fast pythonic counters
from scratch without using something to
get her tools and if you don't know
there's a great introduction by GM Duke
which you can check yourself I want to
kind things in a functional way pi tools
pi tools allows you to use functional
programming techniques in Python if you
want to make it faster there's items so
it's a good method right so if you want
to make something faster just invent a
new library and puts I in front of them
and you can get things like frequencies
and you can even use things occurring
you know you can do pipes you do filters
into maps and current bikes and you get
the same result which is a lot faster
and suitable for those of us who grew up
hacking in high school so it has some
grid virtues right as composability
purity lazy and they also support things
like cereal ability so they're easy to
accelerate and paralyze the great thing
with tues is entirely built on pythonic
data structures so your dependency graph
is like non-existent it's entirely built
inside interlude so I'm not going to
talk about pandas in this talk
unfortunately it's fast becoming a
stable and core member of the PI data
stack it was chatting to some of the
core devs and they were saying like you
know hasn't moved into the middle of the
stack or not they're not quite sure yet
it's really useful for index the other
like time series of CSV file data and
stats models and seaborne already
consider it a core member of the stack
I'm not going to talk about numpy either
but you kind of have to mention it x-ray
and ask because you're going to talk
about later on or I either dependent on
tour strongly influenced by it pandas
depends on many other projects like
sci-fi depend on it and the recent
improvements like I already said or like
insert attic sugar and speed
improvements so that's the end of my
interviewed x-ray you've got labeled
heterogeneous data you've got nopee
arrays plus labels so let's be excellent
for scientific data so a classic example
this would be weather forecasting you
know and this was the use case it was
invented for
an x-ray looks like this you take Anne
on PA you know you you apply coordinates
in two dimensions then you can build a
data array out of it and you can do like
locations and indexing and all this
wonderful stuff really quickly and
there's plenty of examples of my
notebooks and you can look at things
like this and you can see the data
structures and this is very useful if
you ever run into the challenge of
dealing with like multi-dimensional data
like this with labels but that's not
quite good enough right so right now
everything I've talked about has been to
deal with in memory right and but I want
to decouple right I want to D couple my
expressions from my back end why can't I
do like pandas like things on postgres
I've some data in CSV some data in HDFS
or PI tables and some data in my sequel
database I still run into in memory
problems and I'm not allowed to use a
fancy cluster or something like that
well I bigger than I can round data
gathering a bigger machine is overkill
even though it's like three euros sixty
or something like this on the AWS so why
am I analytical expressions tied to my
data structure and why can't I have
expressions to work across data
structure and storage well you can
there's blaze but so what's plays so I
did some research I discovered this
right so this is one problem of the PI
data ecosystem right there's an
ecosystem within an ecosystem which is
kind of cool and interesting but also
like where do I start right you know
well you can get someone to give a talk
that's one way but but I mean these
things are like you know expanding all
the time like and i'm pretty sure that
right now these things are out of date
right so you got plays you've got an
interface to query data in different
storage system you got asked which is
awesome with low as you do parallel
computing through task scheduling and
blocked algorithms you got use this data
description language and you've got
these various things like odo for data
migration i'm going to show a few
examples of this throughout the talk
so we're going to use odo and blaze in
this demo data ship and I and II are
awesome but I don't have time to talk
about them so you can take place and and
you can take your your your your data
set like that's in like a nice pandas
dataframe and then you get this kind of
like expression this symbol and then you
can write your your mean age so you've
written your expression for your
analytical to thing which is a mean or
or an hour's kind but you haven't
actually computed anything yet so it
just stores it as a symbol and then you
tell it what computation engine to use
so for the first example I'm going to
use pandas and then you get these kind
of results which you would expect let's
compute it in Postgres right because
that seems like a really good idea so
you can move from you're using odo you
can move from your your data frame into
a postgres table and the hardest part of
this was setting up postgres and then
you can compute and then you're left
with a selectable and then you call 02
again and you're left with your results
so the advantage of this is that
theoretically this could be a spark
cluster in the background and I've not
had to change any of my thinking about
my analytical task so this is like this
decoupling of the computation engines
from the expression engine we're going
to see a few other projects like ibis
from from West McKinney that are trying
to do roughly similar things Anakin
stored and be calls will CB calls and
see table the storage format later the
only reason I did this was because I
could and it was possible I was
interested in how many different data
formats odo allows you to play around
with so what else you can use any sequel
supported by see Carl coming in your
computation so it supports Python lists
spark data frames MongoDB if you want to
suffer through that and non p arrays
but right now so I've kind of like
blazes Great right so I've got to
certain stage you know and I have
thought about this and I've used
postgres because it's an awesome piece
of software but I want to maximize my
speed of reading and writing on a
singular computer so be kohls is a
column or data store for fast data
storage and retrieval with built in
high-performance compression and
supports both in memory and item memory
storage and the public service
announcement is that it's release
candidate for 1.0 is just out so it
could even be 1.0 as I speak so you go
fast import I put it leverages blush for
compression which is something too
complicated for me but I can use these
things because it's in the pi d @
ecosystem for certain problems like
reading time series and doing analytics
this can be useful another thing I saw
was for bioinformatics data so like you
you generally are only a pending and
reading what you see you know like well
as like some of this data expands you've
seen immature projects like a store
built on top of it and we'll see more
more tools leveraging these fast
compression structures are some great
synergies with binary formats like hdf5
so you can read it in and then you get
this like this kind of this data
structure here Lee it's a CTL formula
tells you all this compression that it
does and then you can look at your calls
so you know it kind of feels a bit like
pandas and then this is an interesting
benchmarked i did so i generated one
gigabyte of data and i are then i
imported it into be calls using in
annecy table and then i looked at how
much compression I got so originally my
data was one gigabyte and now I've got
it dying to 100 like 51 megabytes so
it's about seven times compression this
isn't all entirely so you know this is a
project that most people don't know
about it's already out there you know
and if you're dealing with like large
arrays which is a common problem and say
like image analysis you know it's
that ability to have compression is
invaluable like especially if you don't
want to like move on to a bigger machine
or something like this and then you can
do things like fast numerical
calculations it's got great integration
with nomex Bureau and to handle
expression as got intelligent use of
caching and multithreading to optimize
numerical calculations so let's look at
the adult data set again so that was
another data set I looked up so you you
know so it makes it this ideal for
storing something like a market data and
it uses chunking what you can do pound
is like things right you can select you
can do these kind of like sequel like
queries you're looking for work class
all equal to state government and you'll
get in your stuff back and this of
course could be a one gig about you
something that seven times compressed
right so you can't do that immediately
impound is because it's generally in
memory and there's some challenges with
integration with the recipe idea but
this should be stabilized and please
sound pull request to these projects so
I'm I was looking for a case study of
people who've used it and I asked a
friend and he's a cuanto peon Thomas
Becky and he says they use a Bicol so
cuanto pions Ackroyd source hedge fund
and they wrote up a report of why they
chose big holes so you have a lot of
market data you know it's always getting
bigger and they they have certain limits
of like of speed of input and output and
because of this compression ratio they
were able to like you know retrieve it
really fast which is just invaluable for
the kind of problems are running into
which is your new england equities
prices and there's a link to their talk
when they go into more depth about why
they picked that on why they made this
choice okay so finally your data is
bigger than around or it's in a cluster
you can use desk or specifically task
array
dusk looks like this looks very similar
to numpy and pandas you were very
similar like threads coming through in
these these api designs and you can do
things like i was doing a bit of
exploration of the points of interest
data sent this is in my my ipython
notebook the point of interest data set
comes from open street map and it's a
list of things our points of interest
like pubs schools all these sort of
things so I was going to look for pubs
but then I thought that Giovanni would
make jokes about that so you're looking
for schools instead so I'm just entirely
using this API and you'll see here that
you know it's very like pandas right
here so the second line it's very like
pandas butt is this here is now not
computed right it's only when you called
ed compute that it computes these things
and so we can we find that we have about
300 42k schools in the UK in this data
set and Ireland and then you can compute
these things in in task and you can you
know very similar to the pound his API
you're just computing something about
longitude and latitude and then you
could use back pot lid to plot all the
UK and irish schools in this data set so
this was a bigger than round data set
that i was dealing with for the purpose
of this example you know but i was
entirely able to compute it would i
change in computer or background or
dealing with dependency issues and plot
you know i graph in much the same way as
i would have with pandas with a smaller
data set so we're already seeing like
enablers that means that you don't need
to even change your like your user
interface or you're a mental model of
how to attack a problem that by clever
use of data structures and multi
threading and various other things
they're exposing these tools to use so
when do you use task so medium data
which I define is greater than rom size
but fits on disks Jan read ask comes
into his own around 16 gigabytes
anything around one terabyte greater
probably needs something like spark and
the benchmark my own laptop which is
standard laptop four cores of body eight
gigabytes around and there's actually
many distributed arrays like once again
like if we look at the ecosystem and we
find projects that we never knew existed
you know we could distribute it arrays
like bolt back by spark we've got dissed
array from an thought we got biggest
which is a kind of distributing the rape
as a virtual and you could ask donna ray
and there's probably another project
already been added to this list as i
speak and spark and i'm not going to
talk about spark because someone else
already is but it's a very exciting
technology for the jvm community and
it's good we go recent improvements of
pi spark and interoperability
improvements in machine learning library
and i'm at rockland points at this last
point like it really comes into his own
when you get lots and lots adjacent
blobs on many many nodes interlude i
want to speed up my coat so this here is
probably incomplete as well right
because there's probably other libraries
that i haven't included in this but this
is roughly what you would do right you
do something like number you know so
fast llvm JIT compiler there's easy use
by decorators even I could use this
siphon which I can't use because it's
complicated it's like a weird language
but it's really good and it allows you
to use things on many many computers and
not deal with like the dependency
problems of number and you got pi pi
which is a great compiler but
unfortunate doesn't have great support
for numpy code although i think they're
improving this recently and there's a
new released i haven't evaluated there's
plenty of tools online as new tools are
arriving so so we've got the kind of
like small data and we've talked about
medium data let's talk about big data
and inverted commas um so there's being
when Rob story give a similar talk like
this last year in Seattle he said that
he felt that Python could easily handle
HDFS
and so the DAST people actually went and
handled this problem so I haven't fully
evaluated all their case studies and I
know that they're still evolving but
there's examples when if entirely using
the same API as I showed you they're
using a distributed node of like cluster
four or five computers with a very large
data set of github stuff and entirely
like the pandas API and you know were
able to do things in a way that you know
otherwise you'd have to move from Python
to the JVM previously with something
like spark and so I think like my only
recommendation is of you're seriously
interested in this just look at Matt
rocklands website and he's got like
amazing blog posts and we're just going
to seep idea to getting better and
better at dealing with big data and soon
you may not need to use JVM to deal with
HDFS but other people are going to talk
about support so these are kind of the
things that we're seeing right we're
seeing like lots of little you know
projects lots of things that sound kind
of like contrary to our notion you're
like you know Tyson's a slow language
python County were big data python you
why do you use it all these sort of
things but we're seeing people solving
some of those problems that means that
most of us who think in terms of like an
analytical way won't need to worry about
like going on a high performance
computing course or or learning about
all these sort complicated frameworks
that Shawn was talking about yesterday
from cloudera but people are using a
bioinformatics and this is a project I'm
very excited about so there's arrow and
APIs and I talked about them the same
because they're kind of the same people
are involved the arrow project which is
a project for a software standard for
better in memory in better collamer
memory structures and this is kind of
the problem that i saw this is from West
McKinney's blog posts when he said why
should pandas users care about arrow and
one problem that you run into whenever
you deal with these data sets like is
that you run into like interoperability
right so you actually have to copy
things from Impala or hi previous to
these technologies then dump them into
some hdf5 or CSV format format and then
eventually get it into pandas to to
really deal with the data in like an
analytical way and there's a few people
in the audience are going yeah yeah
we've run into that and the arrow
project is you know to act as the
interface here so you won't really need
to worry about these like performance
trade-offs in the future that's achieve
ingush if this project works and this
will work for all sorts of other data
formats like Park a spark and cooter and
whatever else comes dino aligned because
I given up trying to predict what there
is so abbis so when Rob story talked
about this last year Eva's only
supported Impala well now it is thanks
to the work with weds and various people
working with him now supports equal like
so in just like one of the lightning
talks I'm going to talk about Pokemon so
this is a Pokemon a secret like database
um and you know and this here is
entirely applying this line so I've
loaded this table from a sequel database
I don't need to worry about sequel
anymore and now I can just do my kind to
my value coins you and the same way I
wouldn't plan this so like if you have
people in your team like they no longer
have to to do a switch from one language
to another and that context which is a
really slowing thing in any workflow
like in the future you like or in the
night right because it's works for
sequel life you know in the future
worked with stuff like post grass and
other technologies and so you'll be
entirely independent of what your data
storage mechanism is and you'll just be
thinking about things in an analytical
way and I think that's really exciting
you know I wouldn't have imagined a
couple of years ago that people would be
coming up with crazy stuff like this
like
so because ondrea's did a psych Hitler
map and I someone I think it was Thomas
vaca said maybe we should do a PI data
map and I was like okay so I've done it
um and it's controversial because
everyone is sure to tells me oh but I
wouldn't organize the map that way so
it's on my blog and it's like you know
starting from your question like are you
in memory our term memory what's your
datasets do you have how would you
attack these problems um unlike and so
like any simplification your abstraction
its controversial but if you want to do
a better one do your own and put it on
your own blog so you can see that on the
blog I'll tweet it out afterwards and
this is what it looks like so I'm thanks
to fiverr.com for doing this because I
have no design skills but this is the
kind of question to ask I mean you could
imagine that you could put this on your
wall like in your data science team I
like and as your onboarding people you
could like have a flow chart they could
refer to rather than like banging their
heads against like the wall of I'm
running out of memory I need a new
cluster or something because I've run
into lots of problems when people's
first attitude was lets you spark like
know you have a floppy disk of data but
you don't need that yet so this is an
attempt to answer that in the PI data
ecosystem
so that's all good cuttings fun but what
we really care about or I really care
about statistics so I want to do
statistics and machine learning there's
lots of cool stuff and pandas land
there's pie mz3 of course this was
coming up and there's been recent
improvements in the documentation it's
entirely written on top of Theon oh
we've got time theories examples basing
logistic regressions model evaluation
functions on public service announcement
it snowing beta please use it break it
see how we can go you we want to get
this like really up to like a proper
release state and you can do things like
bayesian logistic regression and at some
point i'll give a proper talk when i'll
explain why you would use bayesian
logistic regression vs normal aggression
this is an example that i wrote up with
the adult data set and it's entirely
with a nice syntax and nice API okay so
stats models public service announcement
if you want to help pi data a lot please
work on stats models it's a great
project project but it needs to
accelerate you know because other
communities are doing a lot better than
we are scikit-learn of course andreas
talked about this yesterday and lots of
cool improvements chat to andreas he's a
lovely guy m and he'll tell you about
what's coming up in 0.18 if i want to
analyze text well there's
production-ready NLP toolkits out there
there's spa see which was recently made
MIT license there's jensen which is
awesome for topic modeling and very very
fast and people are using this in a
production capacity so you don't need to
move to spark even to do an LP the
future what's coming next apache ro as i
mentioned new things like a
functionality for jason like data and
closer to native performance with python
extensions like apache spark there's
many computational tool kits I've left
some bud i'm pretty sure
or but there's like lasagna siano
tensorflow very exciting you know data
care us and cafe and some of these are
written on top of each other and the
older pen or each other as well but
that's an entirely different talk so
kind of like as I like because I'm on my
soapbox right now I just like to remind
you it won't does not simply develop
software like developers so please cite
send poll requests and please help them
focus and finally the feature of the
stack like any of these things is up to
you right to the people in this audience
we've done really well when we can get a
lot further thank you very much
you